you may recognize this man he's a lawyer
he represents the porn actress stormy
Daniels in her lawsuits against the
president and Michael Cohen but in the
last six months he has become famous in
his own right he's now one of the most
consistent fixers on cable news in this
country he's appeared on it at CNN and
MSNBC literally hundreds of times but
he's moving beyond being a mere
television of celebrities now talking
about running for office for president
he's released his positions on major
issues he's traveled to Iowa and New
Hampshire and Michigan and Ohio he seems
serious about it we've invited on the
show many times to talk about his plans
but he's always declined until tonight
he's now agreed to appear on her set
provided me give him time to state his
case and of course happy to do that in
the past he's also demanded that we stop
referring to him by a certain
unflattering nickname and we haven't
agreed to that demand but tonight is a
gesture of goodwill we will not use that
nickname because we're always grateful
when guests are brave enough to show up
in person including in this case and he
joins us now thanks a lot for coming on
so I mean we could sit and hurl insults
at each other for the segment already
done that I've certainly insulted you
you've insulted me but you seem smart so
let me take you seriously as someone who
wants to be involved in the public
conversation and ask you about things
that you have said on questions of
policy to flush them out a little bit so
this is you at a rally in July I think
it was a day after the president spoke
with Vladimir Putin in Helsinki and you
were addressing a rally and here's what
you said watch when Vladimir Putin and
Russia into this country in connection
with the 2016 election is no different
than if they would have placed a hundred
thousand troops on our border
this was an invasion it was an
electronic invasion and tweeters to
elect this president so if I had a
hundred thousand troops on our border I
mean that would be an act of war a
profound provocation what would be the
rational response to that if you really
felt the threat was that profound if you
were president how would you respond to
that well Tucker I understood that I was
coming on your show tonight to talk
about the case involving my client why I
didn't I didn't tell you that and I'm
happy to talk about the case you gotta
stop you gotta stop interrupting me okay
because one of the conditions of me
coming on tonight was that you were not
going to do what you do routinely to
guess which is talk over them and
interrupt them so just let me finish
with my answer okay let me finish with
my I said I'd give you a fair interview
I just I actually don't have any
interesting squabbling with you at all
Orca name-calling I've done a lot of
that to you and right I got to me no but
not to my face I could but what's the
point I want to take you seriously I'm
serious okay
so I just played a clip of what you said
at a rally you're traveling to States
because you want to influence policy
direction I don't think it's unfair to
ask you about something that you said
what's the question and the question let
me restate it is you said that Russia
has done something that is equivalent to
putting a hundred thousand troops on our
border that's an act of war correct
and I wonder two things one what you
would do as president if that happened
on your watch and two what do you think
Russia things watching public figures
like you say that we're at war with
Russia what effect do you think that has
well first of all there's no question
that Russia interfered with the 2016
election in a very serious way the only
question is what was the involvement in
Donald Trump or by Donald Trump and his
cronies in the process and that's what
Bob Muller's in the process of getting
to the bottom of but now it's a country
where you go interrupting me again so
how should we respond as I asked you
three times we should respond with the
absolute force of the law we should be
doing everything in our power to bring
those individuals to justice those
individuals that are also in Russia and
let me tell you what we should not be
doing we should not be standing shoulder
to shoulder with Vladimir Putin and
choosing Russia over the hard-working
men and women of the intelligence
community
that risk their lives for this country
sir president has sold out the United
States announced today a new round of
even tougher sanctions against Russia do
you support that I think it's a start
but I don't think it's what would be the
I don't think it's a step in the right
direction I don't think the president
has shown any leadership relief
sanctions are not a step in the right
direction oh I said a step but it's not
enough I believe that President Trump
should demand the extradition of each
and every individual in Russia that Bob
Muller and others believe were
responsible for the election of Medellin
in 2006 I mean if you really believe
that's the same as a hundred thousand
what I'm saying is you're using reckless
rhetoric on a subject you don't really
understand that increases the
temperature between the United States
and nuclear-armed adversary is that a
responsible thing to do I think under
those circumstances I stand by my words
and I think for you to land it's a
hundred-thousand thing I think for you
to lecture me about reckless rhetoric is
rather ironic tucker in light of some of
the reckless rhetoric that you need
gauge in each and every day on the
reckless rhetoric okay so um you've said
that you are a civil libertarian in
effect you're a libertarian on sex
questions and that that's fine with me
does it bother you that the Obama
administration authorized spying on
American citizens connected to a rival
presidential campaign well first of all
I don't think it's been established that
that occurred number the Carter page was
spied on I I don't believe that that's
been established number one that in fact
President Obama authorized his
administration are you gonna interrupt
me for the entire state I'm there just
clarifying cuz I don't think you
understand the question no idea bomb
administration authorized spying an
American citizen connected to the Trump
campaign does that bother you at all
first of all I don't think that's been
established if it was established of
course it would bother me are we gonna
get to the facts of my clients case
don't question first because you're
traveling around the country go ahead as
a commentator on politics and I'm
interested to know what you think I
don't think that's a legitimate so it
has not been established that Carter
page was spied on is that what
is that what you're saying how many
times are you gonna ask me the same
question I've already stated that in my
view I don't believe that President
Obama has been shown to have authorized
the spying quote-unquote Obama
administration why dodge the question
look you traveled here with policy
advisors who've worked on other
campaigns to the show I have no idea if
you'd be ready for a simple question I
didn't I didn't travel here with policy
advisors can I ask you let me ask you a
question I don't think why is it why is
it that you don't call Donald Trump the
creepy porn president he's the one that
had sex with a four month old son at
home okay so my client now without a
condom okay so but you want to
acknowledge that you don't want to
acknowledge that acknowledge it okay do
you believe that he had such yes I do
I've said that on the American people
and you're think it's okay if the
president lies down let me finish my
question to you what is the crime the
harm the injury to your client by Donald
Trump as far as I understand this was a
consensual sexual relationship and yes I
believe it occurred I don't know that
but it seems like it did I'm willing to
believe that it did but it seemed
consensual and then she was paid at the
end of it and yet you and by the way I'm
not attacking somebody else I feel sorry
for I feel she's being exploited you
attacked her for six months I feel that
you and others are exploiting her so I
feel bad for her but I'm wondering at
the inside they do demean her repeatedly
and I really I think you're a hypocrite
let me ask you you want to talk about
the case I'm asking you the core
question sure in the case what is the
injury to stormy Daniels the injury is
is that the agreement that was entered
into was not adhered to by Michael Cohen
and Donald Trump they did not fulfill
their into the bargain
now do you want to talk to the about the
injury to the American people sure why
you believe no but you just you just
want off on this moral lecture about how
it was wrong for the president to have
an adulterous affair and I would agree
with that but you're very outraged
so was your yes you said it's an injury
against the American people that he had
sex with someone his wife he didn't
finish the injury is that he and Michael
Cohen and others lied to the American
people and covered
130 thousand dollar payment and violated
campaign finance law that's why Michael
Cohen I'm not done
that's why Michael Collins just like
little piggy why Michael Cohen it's
great having Gil I understand them I've
been following the news as well okay did
Donald Trump have a moral obligation to
tell the American people that he had a
sexual relationship with stormy Daniel I
don't care whether he had a moral
obligation an obligation no what do you
end obligation to do was not cover it
cover it up and lie about it and commit
campaign finance violations and so right
handy Michael Cohen just pled guilty to
the felony Tucker would it's a campaign
finance violations associated with with
Miss mcdougal and I thought you were
following the protector of stormy
Daniels stormy Daniels is right now
working in strip clubs and little towns
on stage people are throwing things at
her you're wearing a thousand-dollar
suit why is you why are you not paying
her you've profited from stormy Daniels
you've done tens of millions of dollars
with the free media on the basis of your
relationship with her and she's working
in strip clubs you're exploiting her and
you know that why aren't you paying her
some of what you're making sir this is
absurd no you don't know the facts as
evidenced by the fact is she working in
strip clubs are you gonna continue to
interrupt me I do know the facts I
actually know you don't because you just
demonstrated your ignorance because you
didn't even know Michael Cohen pled to
two felonies associated with the can
finally leave that what Cohen did and
I'm not defending Cohen I never have was
a campaign finance fallacious I think he
pled guilty to two felonies so everyone
who pleads look this is what we have an
honest district I don't think it was a
campaign finance violation stormy
Daniels was to perform in Richmond in a
depressing strip club this hero that you
say you're protecting your her protector
why is she working in seedy strip clubs
while you're on television wearing
expensive suits why I'm not exploiting
her why is she doing that because she
wants to tuck her and she's on staff
this is America this is America and
guess what if a woman wants to perform
in a strip club she does so it's even
getting rich even though people I'm not
getting rich even though people like her
even though people like you demean her
to me
you're the one that we're first tour
consistently is a pornstar
and as to me is a creepy porn lawyer and
meanwhile you give the president
meanwhile you give the president a pass
I would do add unprotected sex with the
porn star with a four month old son at
home well you are a moralizer for a guy
video you do know you are a little more
Eliezer you're like is it we're in
church now with a four month old son
okay I'm officially shocked by Donald
Trump's behavior I had no idea it blew
my mind but answer my question why are
you rich and your client is working in
seedy strip clubs sir do you have any
idea how much money ever you're on every
cable show you're running for president
now no idea I know that you haven't paid
your taxes because you've got over $1
ridiculous you know it's not bad I'm
just saying how do you have a show and
you're this ignorant here's what I know
for a fact is that your client is not
thriving and for you to look at me in
the eye and say she wants to perform in
strip clubs with people throwing stuff
at her is insulting to her people don't
do that unless they have no choice sport
if she just likes it is that what you're
saying Tucker now you're the defender of
my client you don't know anything about
your explainer you don't know anything
about my client explain I know that
she's working in a strip you can manage
can I finish please do all right
I've done a remarkable job for my client
and she'll be the first one to tell you
that and had you listened to any of her
interviews or seen any of her comments
you would know exactly what she thinks
of me I am not I'm not done I am NOT
exploiting my client I'm representing my
client to the absolute so when she
pretend to be a Booker from CNN to get
through to you you know that's that's
that's disgusting why don't you shut
disgusting is why don't you drive a
Tamiya client and me and stop calling us
a porn star and a creepy porn lawyer if
you've got that big O Lord do you have
that bigger problem not looking fun
when's the last time when's the last
time you saw porn oh you busted me
actually maybe humiliation porn that's
why I watch you on CNN no but you're
alone I
horn you're dodging with the question
that I have asked you do you believe
that people that view porn should watch
your show I'm not even sure what that
question means but I will say this
sincerely that I have never attacked
stormy Dan yes you have I think you are
exploiting her as I've said five times
and you haven't answered the question
which is why is it that her life has
stalled and your life has you're
planning a new career as a politician
and like so many lawyers you are taking
advantage of her and you pose as a
feminist hero because you are shameless
and the other channels let you get away
with it
but you're an exploiter of a woman and
you should be ashamed of it and your
that is my and your that is our UI
befitting admit without response time
hypocrite more time your I promise to
what you're talking it's nice to see you
yet again twelve minutes creepy porn
lawyer great to see you